foreign
and welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel today we will be taking you
through react.js project for beginners
we will create three clones of popular
apps the best way to master a language
is by programming it in this video you
will see how to create a YouTube clone
Facebook clone an Instagram clone from
scratch by the end of this tutorial you
will be able to create the front end of
all these applications on your own but
before we jump to the coding part if you
haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn so let's start this in a fun
manner so here we are going to create a
YouTube clone with react.js but before
we jump to the coding part let's see how
the YouTube page looks like
let's see
here
as you can see
there is a nav bar upstairs where you
have your logo
after that there is a upload button the
Bell icon notification button and that
mic button in the search bar and it's
written here the YouTube
and in this you will find
home Explorer shots subscribe original
YouTube music and all other things
so let's jump to the coding part and
create the YouTube clone as it is
so open your Visual Studio code
to create this YouTube clone you must
have node.js installed in your system
so let's just open one folder or just
type control
tactics and inside that write a command
in PX
create
react
app and then the folder name that you
want to create
I'll write U to
flow
press enter it'll take couple of minutes
to install all the packages
so let's wait for few minutes
it'll take a couple of minutes to
install all the modules
before until it's get complete let's see
the YouTube clone again
so we'll have this
videos
and here we'll write this
and write this
okay cool
let's go back to our Visual Studio code
and let's wait a couple of minutes more
so
a folder is
created
so let's go to this folder
to do that I have written a command CD
YouTube clone and then I'll hit enter
inside this I will write npm start to
see how project is working or not
so our react app is working fine
let's go back to our code
and open this
after opening the YouTube project that
we have created
let me zoom in a little for you
let's make it safe
after going to this let's open the
app.js file
inside this let's delete this header and
let's see it's working fine
hello
from Simply
learn and let's remove the react logo
save this file inside this let's
delete all the CSS part and save this
also
and now let's run this control Buffet
and that's right
start
let's see direction hello
yes
here
we will write
again
let's add another one
and we write in game I
installed react router
Dom
let's install this
meanwhile let's create a folder or let's
create a file here
the
thought
she is
and
the header dot CSS
the center
inside this header.js let's first
release this
and this we will write
Center
and then let's save it
the chain compilation error let's work
on this first
let's cut this
chart
inside this header bar
let's import first the react
import react from
here
this will install all the modules or
dependencies that we need
but before that let's add the header
here
inside this we'll write import
data
from
and then the
fit
now let's just save this file
let's go back to our
header.js file and in this file
just a second
yes
inside this file
let's go
let's create a function here first
inside the function hit the
now inside this header function
we will return
inside this will create it there
the class name
Shader
said this
so just check
will write something in
H1 Dot
hello
from Simply learn
let's save it
and showing some error
because we have to export it
we have imported the header inside this
app.js
but we haven't
export this header so in the last
write export
default
in the
file name which is
header now let's save it and as you can
see it's showing
hello from Simply love
so going back to our code
let's
open up
CSS page
inside this we'll write some basic CSS
properties that we are going to fetch in
this health.js file
so let's write some approaches
let's give it for a padding
we can do this after a while also but I
have loaded somewhere so let's just give
it a try of giving
all
sizing border box
after that we'll give it the outline of
um
after that let's save this and inside
this header.js let's delete this and
inside this
will write
header after that
we'll write the clicks
after that we will write a line
we are going to give the property to
these in the app.js file but before that
you have to declare it here so we are
going to write a line
items
sent
will give justify content
subjects right just if I can print
and then the space between
after that
in the next line
will give it another
class name
header
left
item
of that EG Flex
and then again the line
times Center
and the height of Max 30.
and x y
let's save it
okay
that's now in this part
we'll write it
let's
we're going to create a menu bar
here
these three lines part we are going to
create first after that we will create
this YouTube logo and this premium ion
so let's go back to our code
inside this let's give it a good class
name
of menu bar only
five
inside this will write
hpg
inside this
a few blocks should be
0 0 24 and 24
let's forget this let's copy this from
the YouTube only
delete it
you have to go to here hit inspect
inside this
will copy this part
we'll copy this
let's see
let's open this
let's find it here only
clear line
paste it here
and then see as
paste it here but for that
we need to form a document
clear code
it's fine
so it's looking good
now
what we have to do is
we have to save it
let's see
we have to add some CSS more properties
let's
add some properties here that we have
declared in the header.js file
we have given here okay let's go start
with the
body part of this
100 percent
after that we'll go
and color
that would be white only
but let's skip it
after that click the font from view of
let's now go to
file
now
first let's add the CSS properties in
app.css file
let's complete this first and then we'll
move on to the header bar so
it will be inside it only so let's
do it first
Li
e
overflow
could be
after that
I wanted
to
be
let's make it as doing difficult
let's try the white
inside this let's give it a color so
we'll be right right it will fetch this
now let's do it for
black also
wherever we'll call this black
it will fetch this
zero zero zero as you know
so we'll go back to the container
everything stores so we'll make this
container as
it's really tough 80 percent
and then the margin should be
of zero percent
and then we'll make it as photo so we
can switch the screen like in Facebook
YouTube
as we can
do this in this it'll reduce the size
according to the desktop
so we can do that here also
so let's go back to another
we have floated the deflect
let's again confirm yeah
root one only
style this
deflect
let's make it as click
after that it should be enough
let's go to
line
and items
Center
excuse from this also
yes
inside this
will give it a line items
Center
foreign
just if I content
face enter
space between
now let's check it
okay now just
put the flex length in the justification
space between
basically cool
so we'll do the Justified content
inside it space
between
after that
we have also
got Justified content
space between and then the single one
inside this we'll write justify content
then Center
after that
we have wrote
nothing as of now but let's go to this
save it
and let's see
a file
thank you
the display here right off now let's go
back to this
and let's edit this
in this style part let's cut this
because we have made The Styling there
and let's not give it a width of 100
let's give it a width of 30 percent
30 pixels would be fine
this should come under brackets
so
okay
okay
this should come under brackets
no it's fine
foreign
will also include the height of this
height would be
this all comes in the
in the this
height of 30 pixels in this also
common good wickets
after that let's check it
let's say this file
and as you can see
it's showing
like this only
let's
switch and then
so we are back to the we need to give it
a padding so it will come here
let's do that let's decrease the size of
this first
I think we shouldn't decrease it but
let's see
this feels fine but let's
give it a try
yeah it's fine
okay let's
move forward
now
let's make it as this cursor as a
pointer because whenever it goes to this
YouTube sign or this 3D lens it will go
to pointer
so let's make it as whenever it rolls
over this or any of these it should be
as pointer
let's go to our code
and let's write here in the class
0.2
icon
pointer
let's save it
first we need to add the CSS file here
for that we'll write import
and then the dot and then slash and then
the file name the file name is
header.css
let's close this
it's not fetching it let's see
why
okay we haven't given it in the brackets
okay fine
let's save it
let's give it a styling here first
inside this
save it
inside this
inside this
and give the padding of
0.7
and then the second should be 15 pixel
let's save it
and see
is it working
yeah as you can see whenever we go here
it's going from cursor to pointer
okay fine
now
let's move on to the next part
which is the logo
after that
will create a logo here
logo
inside this logo
will write
now we go again to YouTube
and then again search for their SVG if
this have
okay
I think it have the sweetie
let's find it
here only
inside this
VG
thank you
let's copy
and let's go back to our code
let's paste it here
it's have pasted as a junk part
so let's delete it and again go back
here
and copied manually
[Music]
it's
copied element
and back to our code let's paste it
here again
let's just
have format document
and as you can see it's coming
right
so let's see the logo again
everything's
coming right
in the Styles part
let's delete this line and let's
copy this from here
and let's paste it
here
let's save it
so you can see
it's coming but it's coming a very
short so let's edit it here only
[Music]
let's increase the size of this YouTube
premium button
go on to this style in this
60 would be a little let's do it the
more
75 be fine yes
let me write
let's start with fine we'll give it a
betting but after a while because let's
create a basic structure of header then
we can just style it
okay
let's first give it a anchor tag so when
we'll click on this
it can be clickable
okay
let's give it a pointer also
inside the class
inside it will write
it again let's save it
as you can see
you have to make it
give The Styling in this part let's do
it after a while
but before that let's
thank you
all right the dog
inside this logo
and create a
guitar
let's make it as empty now
we will do it after a while
after this let's close it
now let's save it so whenever we click
on this premium button it will go to
another page
let's move ahead
inside this let's
give it
styling inside this let's
[Music]
say this let's give it a bedding
[Music]
waiting right
let's give it 10 pixels
it should come under
10 pixels let's save it
and see
okay
let's see this
okay we need to add some more stylings
here
so we can get okay let's remove this and
yeah
cool
okay fine 15 will be fine
we need to give padding from here also
let's first give it a padding in the
header
okay
box or items that we have saved here
okay
that's a box
let's see
this
was 100
it will declare it inside this
now
coming back to header.js file
create
here
first let's now we'll create we are
creating a search bar
okay let's
name of
header
Road items
after that we will give it
the flex content space
align Center
left
or we can just give it this
because we don't want to give it as left
so let's save it
Ching error because I haven't
close this one
no
inside this
place
of input both
inside this box
we'll create another input
type of that would be take
inside the text
will write
again let's
class name would be
search box
says false foreign
to write
search inside this will you have the use
of
placeholder
with the help of placeholder
we can write anything inside this so
let's write search
go to that let's
close this
after that
let's save it
let's see it's coming
like this only but it's having uh we can
change it after a while
let's
come in okay
let's go back
to a code
and inside this let's give it
uh
let's create another Dev
inside this you will write class name
let's search
inbox
foreign
and then
justify content Center
[Music]
okay fine
let's first just
close this and now let's save it
okay fine
now
we need to
have the SVG file here
so we'll copy it from the YouTube
let's see inspect coming back to our
code
native
save it
let's do some styling here
inside this
let's give it
hide
well this would be fine let's go again
further
let's get the input
the box that we have created right now
the search box
let's give it a vertical
100 percent
after that let's be the padding of
zero pixels and 20 pixels
let's save it
after that
let's go to
foreign
let's see
let's now go to click
search box
here
we'll give it a width off
on the person
after that
leave it a height of 50 pixels
moving ahead
will give it a border of one pixel solid
or we need light but let's
for now
okay let's give it a light color
607d
I have wrote it down
this color scheme
8p into
let's save it as you can see it's much
lighter now as you can see here will
decrease the size of search here
after a while and we need to also need
to decrease the size of this
part we can do it after a while and
we'll create a structure
let's
give it a margin
0 pixels and it should be 10 pixels
let's see first that there is more so
we'll give it
the same
yeah
it's fine for now
and let's give it a bad thing
of zero better and
then pixels would be fine yes
after that will come to the search box
inside this search box
will give it a width off
for deep pixels
after that will give it a high top 40
again
I should be inherited or let's make it
as
one go see it
after that the top heading should be
of 30 pixels or 30 percent whichever is
fine
let's save it it's not
so let's do it should be zero percent
for now
you can change the stylings after a
while
but just creating a
structure
solid
let's just delete it and just copy it
from here
let's write it here
after that
okay fine it's
fine
now let's save it
it's not showing the importance is
[Music]
let's see
what we have not
decision
oh yeah
background color is white only
let's see
okay let's give it
the Box comes here
let's reduce the size of speed of box
I think that's
that you would be free let's make it as
25
and inside this
it's all fine
foreign
as we can see here
30 is fine we need to reduce the size
but we can do it afterwards let's see 30
is fine but let's make it as
28 for more section
okay
let's move on to the island
I know imagine is this
I think it's
important
[Music]
let's save it
okay no we don't need that
question only
okay
and the box mod and it should be more
than
it's fine but let's
okay
is the size of the search
foreign
this
so let's move it here
let's not give it a width though
20 would be fine okay now
not this
let's see here
the person would be fine
in here we can reduce the width
and the extra padding that we have given
you can reduce that
so let's start with that only
this one is inside the box that's
and box
let's say 10 only
okay A little let's say
let's see
okay
let's not give it
a person
[Music]
not remote in this okay
and let's now give it the height is fine
everything looks fine
but let's see
what is the mistake
let's move on
inside this
let's make it as a little short
because it's a very long part
to reduce the
this
the word
let's reduce it a little more let's
50
oh okay fine it's well now
let's make it guys
or let's do that 36
foreign
now we'll move forward
with this
now coming back to our JS file
let's go
now let's open our header file
now inside this part
we will write a SVG
okay we can copy it from YouTube we need
to do it
like this we need to add this search box
for that we'll inspect
and here
we can find the SVG
it's coming for for whole
but we need
it's the icons so let's
copy this
copy this from here
and then let's paste it here then format
document
here let's delete the style of
U2 and let's add the style that we have
created earlier
copy this from here
in the slides added
and make it as 15.
and 15 let's save it and see okay fine
it's coming right but let's
give it 20 pixels
then you can do pixel again
this would be a little big let's
make it as 15 only
but it's coming a little this side so
let's reduce the bedding
then
but it is fine
because let's first make it does pointer
so whenever we go here it should be
yes like this
unlike this
so let's go back to our code
go ahead inside the code
will also need to do some styling
so we have created our search box here
so let's move ahead
let's now create a
volume button
for that let's create it a Dev class
foreign
foreign
okay let's copy it from here
to inspect here first
inside this we need to
go to this
button
and save this
it can find
the SVG
let's copy this element
and let's paste it here now we need to
format document
and it's
fine let's save it
and let's see
let's now
change the style
written
and let's copy it one of the previous
and we are following
so let's paste this guy here
okay
let's again copy
okay
let's
did here
and inside this let's make it a pointer
let's save it
as you can see it's coming right
okay fine let's do some editing here
and set this class
let's
do the voice part
about heading all
let's do it
let's give it the flex
deflect
we have to go to earlier
Center
let's save it
okay fine
now we need to change the positioning
here
all right
let's get the size
let's change this
okay fine it's fine
foreign
copy this reflex from here
and paste it inside this
box and let them just save it
okay
see the issue
inside it let's talk back okay
same thing
let's cut this from here this voice part
first let's
let's record this from here and
paste it here
okay
let's now do here some edit things
because
it's not coming right
foreign
so we need not have to write this inside
this inbox field letter
so let's cut it in save it so it's
looking fine now
now let's move to the next part of this
which is the header right
so after this
there let's see
we'll create another
class
let's now create a class right there
class name
the class name will be
header right
after that deflect
line
items Center
after that
we can
go another create another pair of class
name
let's give it a class name create
options
inside this create options
we will write this is sweetly
foreign
let's cut it first
inspect
and select this let's copy this
it's really easy right
let's save it and format
fine
let's delete this style
let's copy this time one we have created
save it in C
it's not coming let's see UI
okay it's coming but in the end
page size must be long here but we can
reduce it after a while but let's do
some changes first
besides is fine
let's now
inside this class
let's
give it pointer
and not in this class
let's rotate a pointer
and then the Mac
B15
okay
after that
we'll do have some changes
but let's
find now we'll go to another part which
is
the YouTube app button
this one
notification bar
we can go to this
class see where it's ending
after giving one
let's create another class
let's see
notifications
notification menu
inside this will again
expect
[Music]
[Music]
let's find out the
thank you
SVT file
there is this
3D file of it
notification button
it must be inside this
let's see
okay
first we need to make another two parts
of this notification bar
first is this ring YouTube ring and then
the notification button
so let's not create this as
notification menu let's name it as
YouTube
uh apps
inside this let's now again
go to the
bar of YouTube and this icons
we will
find the
okay let's first cut this
then inspect
foreign
[Music]
we can write it
copy element
and then let's
write it here format the document
erase this style
increase the style and copy this style
from above
okay
and let's just paste it here and then
deceive it and see the new notification
ring bell is here
now let's
do the notification bar
after this
let's create this
and first
whether we need to make it as pointer
okay let's make it as pointer here so we
can point it anywhere
and the max would be
50.
I have created the
CSS app.tss files here
so
let's now just save it it's giving it a
margin of 50
we can reduce it after a while but let's
do this for a while now
let's move ahead with
another div of class
notification yes
so let's create it
notification
menu
inside this let's
get the SVG of the notification
inside let's find out
where is the notification one comes
yes
but I can't find it so let's
dig inside this
okay
I'm coming down
it's fine let's make it at this only
but let's
just created
let's not create this notification menu
but let's create this
logo so for that
let's first create open now I simply
download page
inside this
let's get this
thank you
let's get this
copy
and let's go back to our code
creating another menu
there of class name
profile
foreign
but I am writing this so let's
format
document
formatted
let's just ID darker we don't need it
let's move ahead
with the class and we don't need the
class also we just need the picture
is here
so we can write the
things after that
so let's
just
go let me create it
and before that let's
alter
t
and then class name
would be
and Max
let's not save it it's showing an error
let's find out
okay
let's find out the error here
we haven't
okay
now let's save it let's see
the image is coming very big let's just
cut this part
let's add the image
from my page only
copy element
going back to our code
to just paste it
we just need the
source code of the picture so let's copy
it only
and then
after deleting let's save it now and see
is it coming or not
okay
for my dead mind
let's now save it it's not coming still
let's see what's the issue here
so the issue here is coming is
I have to open the
image in new tab
then let's copy it from here
and then
I have to paste it inside this
now let's save this file
and then
it's not coming still so let's format
document
let's see the issue
why it's not working
let's let's first and the CSS
image Dot
this
and fit
limit the class name was DP
let's give it a border of
let's give them for the radius of
person after that we will get the height
of
30 pixels
foreign
[Music]
let's now save it and like you can see
the image is coming but it's not coming
right
so let's just copy some other image
foreign
let's see the issue
let's not see it here first
inside this
move it to the screen
[Music]
let's say this we'll add it after a
while
because the spacing is it's in between
the header middle items so we need to
fix this also
but first we need to fix the image part
so let's see what's the issue here
copy element let's copy it again we
don't need
let's see the
let me show here
let's open the image the image is
opening here
but why it's not working here
here okay fine let's add that
another simple long logo only
let's
inspect
open and new tab
involved with this
again let's try this picture
is it working
let's just save it
okay the center line logo is coming but
I don't know why that video is not
coming but let's
find let's cut this
let's
reduce the size of this picture
give it the height of
20
so I would be fine
though it should also be 25 again and
it's coming fine
yeah
now we have created this basic structure
but we first we need to delete this
space
let's go back to our code inside this we
have
given a maximum height so let's delete
that
they have seen it was in the middle part
so inside this middle
let's see
now it's coming like this
I have done one few change in this CSS
file and give the width back it was 100
but now I give it a 65 percent
so our upper body is ready now we'll
work on this bar
you now will work on this thing
home button explore shots in this we'll
add these all buttons after that we'll
go back to the
body part
now that we have created our header part
we will work on the sidebar which will
come here for that we have to create two
files inside this Source folder only
actually click on this and type
bar
dot Js
and another file called
side
bar
dot CSS
so
let's cut this
and this
and let's open this app.js file
and we'll write the
source of this file so we'll write side
let's save it
will show error for us for some time but
let it fine
let's move ahead
and let's create a sidebar
for that first we need to import react
from
react
no
we have been put the
sidebar
to open the folder we need to write this
add tool display also
the sidebar dot CSS
sidebar is also here
now let's create a function here
that's side part
inside this function we'll read
everything
so let's first Return of the class
let's create Dev
Class E
side path
inside this let's close this inside this
let's write
hello from Simply
hello
let's save it
let's see
which one erroring not defined
okay let's see what's there
said bar is not
okay we have to export it also
put fault and then
and let's save it now
it's it's still
the error
let's see
defined
let's see
what's the issue come in here
foreign
let's create a another class
everything will be printed
so let's click the printer
let's create another class
anymore
sorry
foreign
items
please
like items
Center
and then
we will list
close this
and then inside this
like the SVG
we can create it like this and we can
create it like this
let's create it like this only
or we can create it like this one
foreign
Ty
open let's paste it here
format
after that
foreign
I know
25 again
five pixels
cool
we have to make give it a name also
that here it's showing room so we have
to make it in the name for that we'll
use a tag called span
let's remove it
and let's give it a class name
fixed
let's take this off
okay
now let's save it
and see
how to join
ing
to do with some styling here
and let's write sidebar inside that
let's make this foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
but
I don't
active
okay we need to
add here
effective part
so everything
will come here so here we'll let active
let's save it
in here
all right
background color for this one
should be
99 E
after that let's
give some stylings to
very fast items
and set it let's scare is just different
content should be clicks
start
foreign
foreign
see what's the issue here
now I have done some edits here
on this sidebar.tss file
let's go to add
Explorer
[Music]
and inspect
inside this
let's find it it's 3D file
foreign
[Music]
create one
another
place
let's create here
clicks
and then
elements inside
let's see
okay fine
now let's just
give it a name
after this one
like this man to name it
will give it a class name
of
eight
nine
text
and then let's style it here only
wait
let's make it as 200 as of now
let's
close this inside
explore let's save it you can see how
it's looking now
so it goes away
let's see what's the issue here
I think we just need to cut this part
here
let's
scale copy this part
and let's paste it here
and then as you can see it's showing
two things
so we'll name it as explore
after that
for that
let's copy this
like this
foreign
because on the wrong side I have to put
the code here
let's see this class to another name
and now let's save it
as you can see
elevation but it's list a little cut
so we can just
let's save it
doing this fine so we need to do it
okay fine
now
let's complete this and add more parts
here like short subscription Originals
YouTube music and they will stop
we will make it till here so let's count
it two we have created one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten and
eleven
so we'll move back here
and after that we'll just simply
copy this one
and just create status
to
three four
five six seven
eight
nine
let's
just
take it um
but let's name first here as
short
let's
do another one
after that let's give it to me my
subscription
[Music]
after that
it's
moves
let's see the next one let's see YouTube
music
let's save it
into that
so till now it has completed
few more
let's
find
so let's ignore it in The Styling here
the study is done
everything is done but we just need to
add the image
let's cut this
let's move on to the Short Spot
here we'll see it's
in the icons you will find the SVG
just copy
the select the copy let's delete
let's paste it here
after that let's
just copy it's
point
so we can
handle over here let's delete this
and then set okay YouTube shots
without these
let's save it
and text comment
as you can see it's showing the same
shortcut
let's let's move on to the next one
then simultaneously
you will do all of these
cut that say this
okay
and set this
inspect
after going to inspect inside
[Music]
please find out
I can't find this
particular component
um let's see if I can
and this is the
the element
inside
the last two will just
paste it here for a while and just
copied
this link
now control set to just delete that part
now inside the subscription in which
part
we got this Loop
let's save it and see description logo
is coming right
now
like this we'll do in everything here
so let's go to the originals I don't
think so we need original so let's
delete this component
let's first see what it means okay
let's name it as
to YouTube
music and then save this
after that let's
clean this one as Library
after that
let's leave it as history
moving ahead let's
see your videos
on the head
let's see if it does
what later
let's play this w
ow after that let's just do downloads
hit that
it's light
videos
I'll let you save it and you can see
everything's come here
smoothly
let's if you want we can reduce the size
also
that need to go to
this right 11
what is reduced
so it's fine now
that's coming back to our
fake part
now let's get the logo of YouTube music
inspect
in the icons you will just copy element
let's find out here
here
okay
let's paste it here this time
let's
copy the logo
okay
let's just delete it and paste it here
only
something that's
copy this
hidden control red
just delete that
now
inside this
here in the YouTube music will paste
this
let's save it and see
the YouTube music link has been updated
like
this
now we'll add the library history
buttons
laptop here first
let's find out
let's just delete it and
expected from here
here you will find
let's open this inside the second let's
copy this component
let's do
let's paste the code
last and just copy the image
for the URL logo
you know what's in this website
yes
inside the Library we have to paste this
code
now let's save it as you can see
very pretty low wisdom right
it's
but
let's see
here we have
logo
but that thing
to get the
let's copy this
from here
paste it inside them
history one
save it
coming back to your videos part
play pretty
it's history and your videos
okay we haven't
got the history button
tasted that
we need to change that
foreign
let's just copy this thing from here
and let's just
paste it inside here all videos part
let's first find out the Local 4
history
respect
inspect inside this
I will find this copy component
and at last and copy this
okay
copy that
image URL
inside the History part
stay save it
Three is coming afraid
not two more
let's
go ahead
download
site to inside this
[Music]
the part
double copying that
now I'm going to do the
downloads component
let's just save it
see
watch download
last one is missing that's the
like videos
okay go back again
inspected
inside this part here
yes VT
copy that
okay let's
copy this
and add it inside
like details component
let's
save it let's see how it's looking now
this is our clone
this is
Instagram clone and this is our clone
so we'll make
now also
this part
fill out these components only
let's create the filter component
okay
it's coming back to our
code
let's cut this Pages because they will
be done
so let's create a file called 3D filter
Dot
which is
another one is
dot CSX
so let's open the first file filter.jss
not JS
but first we need to add here the file
source
but
Theta
let's save it
let's see here but it's fine
import
filter from
filter
now we can save it
it's nothing but let's
see you
scream
because we haven't wrote anything inside
this let's start by putting the art
from here
moving ahead let's first
import me part
which is the styling
clear the part of that file which is
filter.css
okay
it's not showing because
of this part
so we'll remove this part from here
inside this we will create a class
let's name this class as main display
main display and inside this
will write that
filter
now let's save it
let's make sure it's there
let's see the issue what's the issue
here
we have given the header side part and
the filterable community let's
let's first create
a basic structure then we can see
let's just go to filter component
and inside this filter
let's create a function
inside this function
I'm really good glass
you would be filtered again
inside this filter
looking great
H1 to C
hello from Simply
love
to see
whether it is in the correct format or
not
save it it's showing an error let's find
out after this
let's see it's the error
we have mixed export it again
export default
and then the file
let's now save it
let's see the issue what's coming
inside the filter only
module not found okay I have wrote
at the wrong spelling
but it's gone fits the filter
let's save it
now as you can see
it's coming straight
fine
let's just
focus on this now
but
filter
I have written here a property of filter
to give it a flex 0.8 and we are giving
it a 0.8 if you remember we have given
this header.css property
of 0.2
somewhere inside the side part GSS
I have given it the property of like 0.2
so Flex is what this screen is a flex
and it is divided into so many parts
so this part is it's taking 0.2
and the leftover path is taking 0.8 so
for videos and all of the stuff we need
this part
so we are giving it a 0.8 percent and
into this we are giving it 0.2 percent
so everything is clear now so let's cut
this file
inside this let's see all right okay
return
[Music]
of having done its value
let's now save it
and as you can see it will be
show here
hello from Simply them but it's coming
here but we want it to come here
so let's see what we can do
so it's coming here so let's do
something to say
let's let's give it this time
display
[Music]
after that
Flex be fine for this
now let's save it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go just cut this part
let's
create a class
here let's edit this in the filter
d
number
line
great guns
Center
inside this let's create
creating these filters are very easy you
can see here
and I'm creating it's very easy to
create
let's just get its smallest to spinning
the filter
let's just close it too
it's like this let's create this fan
so we can write
your name
see first name would be
all
right let's okay
items
0.2
active Roots always show that in this
page is one
we are on
the
lastly let's close this
and inside this Android or
let's save it and see
ing you here
let's change its size
let's go to this part
foreign
property
over here
let's write 50 pixel
so it should come up
and let's give it to Martin also
zero pixels
[Music]
and 10 pixels right
let's save it as you can see it came up
like this
so
let's go back to
fan class Vector item
okay
so let's write span
filter item
items
and inside this
that's right
now let's give it a font size of 16.
so let's try
font size
16 pixels
after that
let's give it a wedding
pixels and from right it will be 15
pixel
let's give it a border radius of 23
pixels
after
and after that let's give the borders so
we should come like a box type of thing
fun pixel solid
I only play the color the color that
we will beneath here is in e
and e and e 5 C
31.
let's save it
I'm receiving this let's see
as you can see it's coming
like this let's decrease the size of
this box
yeah it's like
a little bit
so let's
answer 12 would be final
eleven
who wants let's make it 10.
after that
it's
it's fine
no
you do this whatever
[Music]
it's
two months
into a screen tip now
and then we can
see it's
invites it's not
I'm going to be in this
screen did I run only
everything looks fine in here
it will create a lot of like this
then we'll get a good idea about how
it's
let's give
that's fine
put it though
is that
free type items
okay let's go down here
we'll write Downs
Lord
active
this first one
okay
let's give it give it a background color
black
after that in order we have given
earlier only so we will say none
and the color is that is
but that is
the margin
of zero pixels
and 10 pixels
okay let's see what happened here
let's see
let's see what's the issue here
to instructive
to find
this again
let's give it one more
[Music]
let's
copy this one
it's paste again
mixes
save it
so you know
actual remote desk
and now we'll go back to this one
and now let's see
it's visual
and um
okay
let's see
okay
you know you find any difficulty
including
let's just go to inspect
and then you will find everything
whatever you'll be looking for
inside this
one module is this one
this is
the second module is to this one
okay these two are coming
so because I guess
okay let's just cut this
right okay fine
as you can see
both came up
so we need another one
let's give it more
moments and
then we'll find font says p
let me explain what the radius
I guess
but it's not showing
but it canceled on let's see the issue
here
now let's find out
what is
so this I have given this one active
now let's see
pointeractive
with the prince was
be through her
let's give it a color again then let's
find out
what's the issue here
oh it is going down
foreign
now
as you can see here
the mixer is coming right but this one
is not coming
let's just give it a background color of
black
let's just
do blankets this
fine they're coming good now
nowadays we used to just copy paste this
let's copy paste paste
paste paste
and paste paste paste
now
Will Open YouTube and then
watching this
right follower
which is
Music Live
let's add one as
simply learn
let's move guys
filter
programming
react
which is
viewed this
I want to tell you about these amazing
course that we have on react.js
let me show you guys here
after watching this video
this is a full course
applications there are so many things
they have taught in this full course
you can definitely go for it
and here you will learn so many good
things about react
and also you will learn how to create
projects in clear
coming back to our code
let's just save it
and it's coming like this you have to do
a little padding
that we can give
because the wrist is fine
and also we should kill one Arrow like
this
you can hear that
okay let's see it's
delete everything
going back to filter.css
and say this let's give it
[Music]
suits
needed
okay let's
go for it
okay
let's go to border
left
which is being done
after that
let's
moderate
money as well
pixel
solid
and then the color I want
five c one okay hundreds
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's monkey with solid
but it's
come
seven is fine
it's always also go so it's
it's five
minutes let's add a arrowhead
[Music]
more good
after going here
inspect
inside this icon
copy this limit
coming back to our code
to this it's right
create
a class name
[Music]
inside this
we are going to
add a c
and qsvg
comment document
and after that
everything is
let's save it see
okay it went out
let's see what we have done wrong
there is good
let's see
I will not come here
see the issue
okay we have given it the same studies
inside this time
where it should be what mountain
it would be fine
because everything or let's get a 17
pixels
so now and as you will see
the alt will come back so let's increase
the size
[Music]
let's give it up everything so it will
come a little low
on this this
let's skip it
everything is digging it up on you
it's still 16 good
you go back let's see
this one
that's good email
I couldn't just find let's
starting this way
it was not coming right and everything
is coming right
so you can see here everything's look
great
nice
now we'll add the videos inside it let's
just save this one
please remember let's cut it
you don't need this one also on right
now but
this one you don't need right now I'm
going to use the card the new file that
we are going to create now
so let's move ahead
now we have come to the last component
of this video
here we will add the videos
then
like this
it's got this control one
like this
will add
no videos here now
so that let's create
two files let's name it as
videos
Dot Js
and one for styling
video dot CSS
inside this
let's import here at first
the largest from the art
after that let's create a function
let's do that windows
this time I'll export first
you will always forget to export
this time I will export
videos let's
now let's import the CSS file
videos dot CSS
now inside this
will return
class name
okay here
let's just
delete it last name
in fact that
I see videos
close it
and type this we'll write what
Center
let's cut it because
this will open the videos file for that
you also need to create another file
also
it's created
single
video
Js
in this we'll write our code for one
videos and inside these videos part
there will come all the videos like the
head
in the video.js file we will write the
logo in the description in these views
and all
will write inside this video.dss and the
editing will be done by CSS so let's
move on here
let's just cut
cut
let's just cut this filter component
from here
and let's add the video component here
videos
component here
let's save it
now
coming back to videos component
inside this
to say this
filter
let's see
let's try to import and then you will
see
filter will be
installed
automatically it's open let's just save
it
now let's see each human error inside
the wheel reduce part
okay let's just first give it
a little
CSS
logos inside this let's give it a flex
[Music]
because we are using
back here
and let's scale with the
let's just add this area is showing
because
we have not
imported these videos here you just
remove the filter
let's import the videos part here
we just need to write videos and
everything will be done automatically
now let's save it
again it's showing an error on the
videos outline
let's it's not returning the function
let's see the issue here
okay fine
we have given the wrong name
so let's do the right name here only
yes yes
meaning
set is safe
now
you can see it's working perfectly fine
isn't it looking amazing yes
let's move ahead now
with the video components
let's
insert this let's create
last name
is rho
space
I mean it's
go back to similar video
here I will write
code
oh yeah
to create a function
of single
video
inside this
let's click on
let's go
where he was headed as condominant
so let's return
there
last name would be
c o n one
let me save this
let's go straight the next one without
reading
hello from
Simply
Save It and see it button fine
let's just see how the files do
I mean
inside this we have two
go back to reduce component and then we
have also need to call it
cylinder
three two
now we have imported this one here
let's see
how it will work single video component
of this
will come inside this
one after that
we have to declare it instead of State
the header also also will declare
single video
from
single video
save it
and let's see
error
what is uh it is
I mean
you have to do yeah in the video open
and we are entertainment strongly
development
in the single video also here we go
ahead
now I'm going to work on our
single video page
let's open that
okay there was no
as I have told you earlier I always
forget to export the file so
this is a very bad heaven
as you can see
hello from Simply learned is shown on
the screen
now let's delete this part
we needed
now
we will
let's create one's mail image
thumbnail it's just
simply I'm showing it everything to you
guys
please
inside this will give the image source
that we are going to give
and let's give it
alter
knock the rank your class name of
some
image
click save it it's showing another
let's see what's the error
we can delete this you know plan but
whenever we add the source it will go
automatically
well let's work on this one only
okay find your name
if you want we can just
make it like red line also
but it's fine let's create it like this
only
let's insert this function
let's begin with my first only
insert this function
yes
let's now want to insert the brackets
[Music]
on
to that profile
okay
okay
let's save it now
the file
that I tell you also typing
declare
[Music]
inside mobile
after that
inside there let's try it
will be needing
news
Einsteins
and the last one is the video
description
you can have it or not but stand it
or let's
go
it's on video
here it is
now
and set the return
we'll return the ID of this
to that
the image
the elective
let's run overhead
with this
very easy
image source
of
that
the image search would be
some
more in the head alter
PNG
let's see okay
after that it's
so whenever we will click on this
picture it will show us
pointer so it's
time to let's save it
let's type it also here
at the back it's straight Style
you save this
let's give it our width
and the width would be
after you close this brackets
so you can get a free idea
you can move this pan
Plus
videos
let's create another day
say this
option marks
this option
[Music]
then D6
let's do that
and we'll give it
the class
you can say that guys
profile
image
so let's
click on that profile image
inside this let's create this model so
and everything later
image source
image source would be
the profile
Bridge
now
set this image only let's give the class
name
so I'm good
[Music]
let's create that here only let's
on here
and after that
that's not true this
yes
moving the head
let's go back to our views it happens
added any of our
videos so we have to
take some time
let's go here inside it now
let's go back to our code
and that's right here as
if okay
[Music]
and it's right here
the title of that image that we are
going to add
after that let's give it a deep Flex
half the time
a line
items
after that yes
25
and
afterwards
let's create a new also
classy
the real name
okay
after that let's see that this
[Music]
right
like this we have to create one
another one
inside this the only so we'll write
class name
the class will be
okay
lastly for this week's dining
is
actual computer
to do this
okay fine
everything is cool right now
let's just write here description
description
after this one
inside this
span
plus new reviews
and then
okay
you can search it see
after this one
let's create a narrative and Stamp
last name
from this
okay
related
to these times let's look at that only
further
call it let's call it time stamps
so
this is ready
let's see
let's come to this one I have given it
inside
so
expand
let's save it
five
is the
nothing will be leaving right now
because we haven't edited the videos
which we are going to add inside
look
let's just cross check it
inside this
now we have given so many
reviews here
let's see by adding a video here and
that
is it working or not
so let's add the video here
I'll just add the English link
that is create class
ES
class name
and
let's try this aesthetically accountable
the thumb we met
inside this let's try to use Link
let's add each link from here
to go to ur
down okay let's
add this equivalently
copy image address
images is copied here now so I will just
paste it here
then
let's save it
and see
is it coming so beautiful right
yes
let's
more standard
inside this
really
100 work here next now
write these things under this let's try
and open this video
thumbnail you can copy from here
okay
hi guys please subscribe to our YouTube
channel
thank you so much come back to coding
let's just add the
let's add
now
we'll write
profile
image
inside this
okay
we will add this link only
on let's add another one
[Music]
okay
I'm copying it from my iPhone
let's paste it here
after that let's save it
and see it's coming already big
let's style this
let's sign in
inside this
let's see what we can do here in the
profile image
the style would be
and then Center
let's write the CSS for video
okay
and first
title
let's give let's go on size
16 pixels
after that let's give it painting of
zero pixels two
five pixels
after that line
rate would be
again 600
and the color would be
let me again copy this
CSS from my previous project
would be nice let's go save it
no I'll copy paste some of my previous
CSS that I have wrote
let's save it
here we have declared this uses file
video
save this one you will match the
like I am going to
let's look at this Flex like this
time option
make as you can see now it's coming
like the logo with that we can see on
the
YouTube
but it's coming like this
so let's reduce the size of this first
let's see where the logo is
[Music]
are you
need
let's give it
a little puppy
this is screen
this is
now let's add the
part okay
so that we can add a video full video
here
so I'll write the
after that let's add the description
title channel name and Views and all
here
so for that we'll write title
inside the title we'll write
what we have opened here was the
reactable course so we'll write react
of course
2022
let's now
name here
and that you know very well is our
YouTube channel it's simply done
very nice
you
can put on
after that
let's see the views
you can add views here now
so we'll write
then give views
with that
let's
try it
the times and
the timestamps let's make it as two
weeks
two weeks ago
and the media duration is a full course
so we have to write
five hours
30
33 minutes
and
29 seconds
let's save it and you can see it's
coming very
like this so let's edit this one
for that let's go back to our
this let's see what you have done here
next is good
uses sizes very privilege
then would be fine
font sizes should be what you would be
buying now let's 12
let's learn how to keep one more than
400
.
let's edit this all
okay let's get this one
Italian names TV you know let's make it
14.
let's see it's coming down but the title
is coming up so we have to knit the
title up
so let's make the type the love
title is not showing here no yes
let's add the title
something giving but it's not fetching
it let's see why
thank you
Google cheers
okay let's post maybe this one
click key so that it should be
open like that
it will be
beneficial for us only
and let's save it and let's
see
if let's
see this
I'm given the
anchor tag but it's not
okay
let's leave this down
so inside this usdp is called
search boxes
also good
let's
see
video duration
let's see
[Music]
oh yeah
okay
you have to give this hair
so let's change so as you can see here
the video of this link is shown in this
part
so like this you can add as many videos
as you want
here by just copying this part and then
just pasting it
so the rest is all fine
so let's just wind up this video by just
thanking everybody so thank you for
watching this video if you want the
source code for this video you just have
to comment it down
and I'll put the source code in the
description box and also I'll upload one
file which is this one
that
I haven't showed you this app.jss I'll
add these properties in the description
box in one file so you can just copy it
and then just
do the coding so let me show you
how a app will look like
here we are going to create a Facebook
clone with react.js
but before we jump to the coding part
let me show you how our Facebook login
page looks like
so we're gonna go to the Google
and this is how our Facebook clone will
look like
you can also log in from here
in this here
you have to write your email address
like my email address is
and I'll write the password and the
password I can write
and then
here I'll click on the login
lastly to say and never and this is how
I will login page main page will look
like
here you can add your status
this is your login your search bar
and here you can also add the status
and this is how you can upload a picture
so
we can easily create this clone
follow me throughout this video and you
will learn how to create a Facebook loan
so without further Ado let's create this
Facebook loan from scratch with a fun
manner
but first let me tell you what react.js
is
so what is react.js react is a
JavaScript library that is used to build
mobile and web applications fast and
interactive it is an open source
reusable component based front-end
library of JavaScript
react is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript
it provides a reverse and opiniated way
to build modern applications
so now
let's create this folder
back to our Visual Studio code
for this
you have to install node.js in your
laptop
and
react yes you can also
get our videos
just type how to install node.js and
react.js
on your system on our Channel you'll get
plenty of videos of this
so we'll go and create
new folder
let's
minimize this
say this
will open our terminal
press Ctrl backtick
or you can also
go here
and press terminal and new terminal okay
now
you have opened our terminal
here
you have to create a react project
so for that
we'll
command
it's just let me delete this
everything's look fine
in this video I will also show you how
to create a shortcut that you can use
which are used by the Developers
Now to create an empty react project the
command is
npx
create
react
and
and then
the folder name
so I'm gonna write the folder name as
Facebook
clone doubly because I have already
created Facebook clone with single e so
I'm gonna write clone press enter
this will take couple of minutes to
install all the modules so let's weigh
the form few seconds till it's finished
let's wait a couple of minutes more
so let's
cut this
okay maybe I have to learn this out
as you can see it's installing all the
modules of the app
ideology at home via script
moving forward we will also install the
add modules like
okay right let's talk about that further
in this tutorial
now we'll go into the
clone
now we'll write npm start
and this will open up react project
so the first step is done here now
coming back to our code
let's open this folder
my folder is inside this
C drive so I'm going to go to this here
users
and this is my folder as you can see
I've already created this video
so
this is how
this one full level look like
inside the source folder you'll have
this
app.js you don't need this logo so
you're gonna delete this
it will show some error let's see
coming back to index.js
let me do very few things here also
but before that
let me add one file here
for a couple of seconds
you can add that further in this
tutorial also
hello
we will remove this logo from here
instead of this it will import
react
we don't need this header also
here I'll write
hello
from
simply done
open Terminal
inside this Facebook loan you have
already in this hole so you don't have
to tell you CD let's zoom in for you
guys
this is fine
so it's showing hello from singular
add to a cone now
let's not waste any time and build our
Facebook app
now let's create a folder here
as login page
inside this folder we're going to create
two files login page node.js
and
login
page dot CSS
inside this GS file we're gonna write
all our code and inside this we are
going to do whatever signing packet
if you're coming back to our login page
we're going to first import react
after input is react
we need to import the CSS file for this
login
okay
okay fine
now we'll create a function
of the login page
inside this function
in the create one
fifth class
of your hands
inside this we're going to create
another class
name let's see the Facebook
text
so these are the keywords that we are
going to use in our CSS file
so let's
add his book
and here in export r
smoking Beach
let's save this coming back to a
codelets and delete this part
and then we'll leave
the login page
and let's call it Insider approaches
okay
let's find the problem here
okay
probably this here
you cannot install or import our file
like this
let's now save it and you can see it's
three
fine
coming back to our app dot CSS
here we go this so we're going to delete
and save this while let's cut this part
okay
you know
came back to our index.js
now we cannot see the Facebook
written in our
um
so let's just see what's speech okay
[Music]
close this
now let's save this as you can see the
video is written so
now let's move forward with our code
let's create this one
let's create another
class name
let me say this we're gonna write before
that let me log into my Facebook account
to see
what are we going to create
as you can see we are going to create
this
let's copy this text
and paste it here
and as you can see it's break after
shift
Define
coming back to a code let's see
the with after one
that's
move forward
after this
let's create a
class name of container
so we're gonna create this argument but
this is finished I'm gonna just create
this one you can study this color and
everything you never see subscribe
last name
here we're gonna add
two login inputs one for this email and
password
so let's fill it up first second word
thank you thank you
email
is a very intelligent language
there we are going to write emails with
just automatically knows that where you
have to write the email ID and then set
this password and I'll give it a type
password it automatically knows it's a
password type
so let's
hold here in this placeholder
let's click on this
this email address or password
placeholder is nothing but what's being
in the right inside this it can't be
fixed
so it's for the user
when we do it
press or
we will explain
let's create
games let's compare them again
another
guide
save this
it's time to see this
and sleep
good looking good
yes
it's coming back to our code
we are going to style this part it'll
look like this only
so just wait a couple of more minutes to
see the amazing love in danger
to creating this facing this we are
going to create a button
back at school
and here we're gonna leave
okay
let's just
delete button
it's created or not let's create it
okay now
coming back to a goal
see it for your password I think
it's creating the price
oh God
okay and inside this I'm going to give
it up
close this we're going to try it
forgotten
another person who will possible
save this and see
and you can see let's have another link
this is all because of the Android app
it's the data
let's quickly address
let's give it to break
us
58
is just
don't say this
button
we need a lot of smoothness
thank you
[Music]
guys
trust me yes
foreign
this button
that's pretty good space
let's create another class name
when you're going to create another type
how to create
create
and after that what's the rest is
foreign
but it's
it's not
save this and see what's sculpted so
everything looks fine like recently now
the amazing part is the styling part now
we're going to style this part we'll
create it like this isn't it amazing
let's go to our code and inside our
view.css
let's come here
let's find it here and
let's
first
okay
[Music]
six would be fine
this part will imply on Earth will be if
this is a binder
same thing
inside this box says
so let's save this
so cute remember
F2
all right if
yes
in this login
reflects all these to this
problem it is
[Music]
[Music]
to fix it up from that
convention please space between
so
isn't it looking fine
let's move forward
you'll get to see everything like this
this login page
going to create a full-fledged in from
so just be with me
okay
and let's
connect
now
some Facebook texting
it's full countries
fixed
and say this let's give the battery also
continue
on Save
me
let's give it a treat
blue but let's add exact color
to
yes
let's see this okay
yes
give after the written list
and say it should be six
six
it's
let's see
oops it's so easy
to create it
it's just more forward
right
it's right right there
for this
yeah
are you Jim
um
increase the size
foreign
do that
it's good
I see between this
so let's give it to the reporter of
eight
let's
give you but a little
let's give it
up
foreign
[Music]
let's see if it's
not
working
this part
we will continue
let's see the issue with the container
so
the issue is here
amazing
it's include the size
of this
things
moving forward
it's
next
type is email
stupid
will be given inside this container
so we can jump
accents
and 22 pixels
[Music]
it's pretty much
yes
also
Define
this
is
now I'm just doing this week from now
and let's
stick to our parent information
so
you don't want to know 73 pixels
same thing should be
nobody box
ES
foreign
also
let's copy this component
paste it here
because what we'll be saying
so
password
let's look on this please if we look
input
please hold them
let's see here for example this is
check there
it's much more
so let's give it a complete that's
looking fine
yes
now let's work on the button part
that
let's give it a display of links
Flex Direction
will be
so it will display this so it's slow
and width would be
good again
so you will copy this
tell me
let's paste it and save this button
again
you know this see
isn't it looking amazing
order
none
same thing
they have content
it's dating you know
it would be 15
seconds
don't even send it
slips okay
if I couldn't pretend
Center save it it's only the center
General
the person that's
just standing
and this would be five frame
should be
okay
next decorations no
that's okay
let's see here
okay everything's looks great
and let's have to see the button
s
you know
if you think
you know
because
already we are going to
delete this part login
but let's see this
is
a little Slim
it draws a bit
this is not good
what do you think is this
listening
let's move forward
and give a standing
that here
didn't help to increase
display always flicks and I've told you
this
will be ready
have it first okay
this
would be between
it's
continent
we do
this
yeah close me and this looks great
at this button
foreign
no
affiliating this
let's work on this button button
it's
let's use this part
icipants
just play
tricks
and just if I could did
Center
color it is a factor will use
this building
is
true for this
that's killed it treatment
it will be
still to hit
yes
surely coming like a button
so let's first give it a trading list
it would be 15 pixels and
conferences
overseas
in this book
see
this thing
is
um
increase
so
should we find the
words of this button 60 percentages
let's move forward
and here you give a bit of
flakes
hold
and what will finish this
25
margin
we have to ref
erencing Magic
looking amazing
right
yeah
so let's
move forward
okay
from this create a page for this let's
feel it on the side user we can do
and every color would be
let's give it an event
you're Justified
Center
it was
sister
should be fixed decoration
simulator let's save this yeah
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
size
font size would be
one
after that let's give it a painting of
left
10 percent
[Music]
let's move forward
with sleep in five minutes
you
know
the opinions
whatever
pretty black
foreign
like this so let's
hear
inside there's nothing much details
it's coming here but
sort of so let's do
add this
which comes after this one
here looks good now let's change the
color
it's not but it's just
and let's save this
changing the color
it's not looking good so
it's not
add this
it's
actually
okay
[Music]
so let's hit this button always list
Ed
okay
that's now save this
so we are done over
it
excuse me
it's looking amazing it's like this only
changes are needed
but let's not dig deep into this
we can also
have a few things
which looks fine to me so
let's not
let's Now work on our
I don't mean please open this
let's create a folder
and
Greenwich
that's good let's Now work on the hitter
button
which is let me log in first
okay
so my Facebook is logged in first thing
we're going to create is this part this
header part the look what is going to
search by whom then these all buttons
and these things coming back to our code
let's open the enter dot so let's create
the files for this
here
dot Js
and then the new file header area dot
CSS first item
let's cut this part
the first thing we're going to do is we
got react
after that we're going to report
the CSS file so for that
area dot CSS
type will create a function of header
area
inside this we're going to return
welcome
foreign
[Music]
let's just see the full screen
inside this lovely button
I'm going to get them
full
so whenever we click on this login
it will redirect us to the homepage for
this Facebook
so we're going to declare the link
to
header
area
and this will drive the object
let's just save this part
we have to declare the react router but
after that let's open our terminal
inside this terminal we are going to
install the ACT router down so for that
we are going to write this command
npns installed iPhone iPhone save react
router down at 5.3.0 so let's install
these files
it will take a minute so
in the meanwhile
I'm going to add one file here
so let's import that also
it's done
so let's let's just close this and go
ahead
import link
absolutely
from
let's save this it is so you can't be
exist
so let's see the issue fine settings
forward
save this coming back to the code
let's see
what this
going back to app.js
here
we are going to report
Universal reaction
I'm going to use route
and switch method here
that's firmware which is
right now I'm going to see login and
let's import
header area from either area
let's just delete the start and inside
this we will hit switch
and switch router parts from one page to
another
you will tell you why we are doing this
you just give me a couple of visits
start
when it's true
we're going to read select our component
and then here's an unloaded
login
let's disclose this here
let's just copy this
movie
and head
we are going to write
header
area
and this is not what we're going to need
here
foreign
so because of this function the page
will redirect from
let's just
start this
is doing what it is it will redirect our
login page to the header page
that's where we have written here out
from login to data button although main
feature
let's wait a couple of seconds to see
the results
okay
it's showing me the error
let's just resolve this error
login page
in the link
[Music]
okay
okay
let's just save this again and let's see
what it does now
get successfully compiled
let's go back to the login page
let's not showing you the login page
right now
let's find out the issue here
but it's not redirecting me
okay
so let's see
now I have added one file here
service.worker.js
you can find all these files in the
description box
I'm going to give a drive link where you
will find all this code for free
so I've also added one image folder in
which I have added few images
like this and I'm going to use in this
so let's close this this
part
it's it's done
and also done so let's
work on this
so I've done few changes in this file
also you can see
that I have important this service
worker from service worker and then
browser out now let's see our output
so it's same welcome to civilian as we
have written in our database let's see
the link is working or not
into a login page here I'm going to
write an email address
yeah
password
and just okay let's show you wrong so
let's just
let it straight welcome to simpler isn't
it awesome let's go back to uh
spending this thing here in the login
yeah
let's just save this
and I'm going back to login
thank you I should
and check on the login it will show us
welcome to simpler
so let's go back to our header India
part let's just delete this
and say this div let's give it a class
name
home page
after that let's create another
yes
huh
inside this header
okay everything's look good
inside this header we are going to write
another class
of meal first hitter
and this
let's give it a class option logo
and then
add up your volume
so inside there is something like image
source of the image is
slash logo dot PNG
let's just see
let's just see the introduce okay
let's see let's see this and see
nice code
let's make few changes of styling inside
this will be
or did this logo
okay
PNG holder
logo
time
let's give it about I just flick
because the directions
okay
let's get a bit of heading also from now
then
okay
let's save this and as you can see it's
coming
right like this isn't it amazing
I'm loving it
let's go back to our code again
and now this logo
we're going to add one
so far it's like this
come back to the code
this part is done
okay
so let's work on our
okay but before this we have to improve
it with another file
let's
actually install the
you can't npm install reactor and I can
save
so it will install all the icons for us
like if a users have register and we are
going to use it no worries if you don't
do that I'm going to cover up in this
video
so coming back to our code
it's just
d
written
yeah perfect
in this spot is done
after this logo part we'll create
another depth
us would be search is fine
search
and save this we're going to add AI
outline
search
I've been doing both these
here also
we'll do that
no shoes
let's just first continue this part
would be fine
okay
let's just save this and draw another
yes well you have it imported this from
the architecture so that's important
hey
root
icons slash
yeah it comes under Air library
let's say this and now
and this logo is coming
nice
lips
and forward
we can know all the changes in diseases
file you don't worry
coming back
let's move forward and let's inside this
we need between four different in the
face on the this consultant search
capital
and the type was
research
swing exactly
this hand side
okay fine
let's now move forward with these icons
okay
let's
and let's create another Dev class
the middle
inside this middle header I'm going to
create one Dev so class
becomes
yeah
[Music]
after this we are going to write a i
said
um
and Save
2.3 but don't but let's try to continue
to the color for this will be
let's see
value will be
okay it's like although you will be
triggered and then this one would be
active so I'll tell you
here number seven
let's close this
study it
has fewer classes like this
yeah
this is funny
moving forward
let's just delete these
will tell you why I have written it
inside the first icon
so
why I have written this in the first
part is
because we need this as a blue and these
are all follows so that's why I have
written here the color wrist Blue app in
this color blue
so
let's stream the names again
so the second one
G
flat
and then the same font size will be
there
30 energy
empty
and then
and d e command
I need you
the fourth one movement
the users
faith
users
and us to one is smart
okay
no remember
okay let's search
wallet
ability
let's see the results
acting for these files
Village
let's forget this
and let's import these parts
so the AI ones will come here and we
need to declare one another one
the slits
hmm
yeah
[Music]
it was like Yay
was it
they're not fitting it I don't know why
Arrow said
oh
it will adjust
let's first complete the code
then let's add these things
that's what's complete this part
and then we'll move forward with the
click on governments
let's create one another div
orce
hidden
inside this header I'm going to create
one
there of class name pulses and its curls
inside this f e
Plus
on
install
it is pretty easy I guess right
let's just copy this component and let's
maybe use this
okay
let's make these names here
I have to add one picture of mine also
here
Facebook
and send you
the seller okay
and the
and then this part fourth one is my
pictures so let's just
cut this part
and instead of this I'm gonna write
image
of my image with key again and save the
image folder
images
so inside these images that's one
G okay
let's save this
okay fine fine
I'm going to close this also
maybe this looks fine but we'll import
our module here AI
will it okay
so it's important let's write all these
Fields here and embodies
okay
to report the MD and the difference so
first we have an entrance board
F components
f a
H okay come on
users plugin
f a
the circles have here
Facebook
and
I see
it okay fine everything's look good
okay what's this is coming
AI
AI outline
it looks like me
okay thank you
through
[Music]
icons
Americans slash Staffing
let's draw this and save it
okay it's not okay
save it let's find now
let's see the output here
it's showing that the md1
on demand
okay
fair enough
we have an important these component of
MD
and inverse
only one
definitely
from
that
icons slash empty left let's save it and
see the outputation
oh it's getting fun
so the Facebook logo that you have seen
here
this is that search box home button
which I have told you that it will be
blue flag YouTube friends and these are
all the buttons in this image you need
to
drop this image into circle like this
so what we're going to do is we are
going to add
pelvis TV
let's alter this
said the style
and let's give it
a height of
40 pixels brackets
now let's save and see
hit the nuts
see here or something
yeah
nice
oh god let's see why it's taking so much
of time
anything for localhost
looks fine to me
[ __ ] right now
foreign
like this
okay coming back to our code
I guess we are done with our header
area.jsp going forward to the sliding of
this let's let's write it
first thing we are going to do is this
HTML page inside this HTML page let's
give it the font size
and the box as it is 40 bucks
moving ahead we will write in right so
it should come under one and only
zero so let's save and see okay
fine
yeah coming back
start style is used to
access everything that comes under this
file everything
margin
and zero percent
now let's give it works on the body part
and set the body region we're going to
divide the same 1.6
then
with the cup
after that the background color
should be
right but it's 0 2
S5
okay
see ya right let's
margin
right
insert this loading right
we'll write zero after that let's
work on this homepage
let me educated
this place should be good yeah
let's look on the header button
inside this header we're going to
declare a few things like this relation
will Flex
and justify content always Facebook to
me or not always between we use space
even you most often
coming back
now
these items
into Center
and right place only will add the
background color
after that the position is
elasticity so we can't move these things
again
from Top
should be zero
yes
100 percent
and then the height
that's right for now
and water would be
fine
and that should be black
and then the margin
let's do detoxes
let's save it and see
these three
in the left
okay cool
move forward okay let's
okay let's just
to see what's the gym we are going to do
so
this is
some dog
this is not perfect
in this big box after this let's work on
and we'll first hit up
first you know
display
checks focusing
yeah
so let's work on into a search button
now the book has come late
search button
inside this let's
just reflection straight
windows
installing window okay
I'm done
yeah
and it would be
to save
it's a good sleep
yeah right now it's time to get great
another next ingredient
yes okay
I just I'm going to create them
again the padding would be
nope
please for now let's see what's
okay but
okay but let's okay we can just change
this
so now
they will first let me like give it a
margin of completed
seven pixels
and this is what we are getting a box
now
I'm going to give it um
creator
it's coming fine okay
this is coming great
it's no search for new thing
research
okay
let's work on this part now
let's
work on this input
thank you please
search
you have to declare here before then
okay then only we can
bad things
great
ly we are going to write like
thank you
healthy
such a smile and I think it's good
after the bedding we're going to give it
a margin
okay
foreign
let's align these items
sender
and the Box saving
water box
playing with
50 pixels
color
brown color
okay let's
go
input
you can increase
call this
one
size
save it
okay let's see
looking looks great but it's
yeah I'm Gonna Save this
let's shoot this so it's coming
like this eight
the search box is coming fine
yep which looks nice let's work on the
middle and this part for that you have
to go here to uh let's uh these I have
copied these instructions
please like these I'll draw some like I
have declare the middle header inside
that I have displayed should be Flex
with these because it should come like
this smoothly and the alignments in the
center which I am giving one person
these icons and all
like this
okay now let's just say this and as you
can see it's coming like this
so let's add
a few things in this fight only
for the loop
the thing should be
a t or like 20 would be your spine
that's right 15
yeah 15 is much better
image should further with 50 or like
okay
let's see versus
this image
so it's testing
oops
some service
emergency
okay I think it's fine
yes
that we could have
a little bit translator
foreign
this looks exactly like this right
now we are going to add few things in
this main page for that
we're going to create a folder here
let's name this I will say this Source
only as
IA
okay I have already created
inside this main area I'm gonna add
two files
yeah let's take this
let's click on your folder in it here
inside this folder
to files main area.js for our JavaScript
code
and for the CSS
meaning the dot CSS
first we are going to open our
connecting for these files here also
it's important
mean
foreign
[Music]
they know you should know
okay
it's looking fine
let's see what we can do and changes
to uh
it's right here as
important
react first react after that
it's really import this CSS file
important
CSS
after this let's
create a function
or the main area
for this immunity to enjoyed
I don't
class
[Music]
I'm going to create one right left
right middle and the left
so we'll start working on the right but
before that
let's see what's T issue again
it's the function only
okay
let's say in the poly Port as many there
was no problem meaning exports okay
let's see okay let's now solve this
issue
uh imported this file
it's done and what's imported this
mainly the appearance that they said
about
I'm sure you also done but still it's
showing you another okay
we forgot to explode
a file export default and the file name
is save it and boom that's showing me
that the right path
now coming back to a code
we have so many things to be done inside
this file
it's not waste any time and work on this
the first thing we're going to work on
is the right
so let's just make our folder here so we
can easily see the right type
let's just close this part
a better place
let's work on this
let's create a Dev class
name would be a passage there will be
three sides here
after this let's create another class
bit of classroom
and the last name would be profile
okay it's not doing anything before that
you look at this screen
and this inside this let's see board
image
in the source of the image I have
imported these images
universe
will always happen
to start this afternoon just do it now
and style it
with your height
or 60 pixels
360 pixels
and per day
of one
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
blue
and the font size
three
children
inside this stuff
and mermaid
friends
let's just save it and show that I have
not imported these icons but I'll do it
later let me show you what I'm going to
do I have declared one this picture of
my need and my name again I'm going to
write this friends groups marketing and
all and then this
from the beginning two or four maybe
like okay
come back to our code
it's just forward let's just copy this
component
let's just copy this and paste it here
I feel nice
okay
so after the user friend I'm going to
add
Fe
AR
awesome
black yeah
we got a little bit green
and one says
after that let's
enter
and let's give you the color blue
[Music]
I think
information
Center
save it
after that
I'm going to infuse with my simulator
for this
after this Kuwait I'm going to write
messenger
Messengers
no
okay there would be green only let's see
if I can see more
let's do it
and let's give it some break
to this let's create another div
yeah this
profiles then let's move forward
in here
after the profiles I am going to add one
image source
yeah I'm sorry images
G
Boulder
logo
study
to understand
indeed
45 pixels
[Music]
in
the
locker
let's
now copy this component
yeah
let's copy this component
here like
a few times
three so
one more for the C motion
okay
everything's look pretty it's fine
forward let's steal the meter then you
just four
yeah so here I'm going to write
the mean stack
attack
JavaScript
and then again we have to Define them
let's add
one more
yes for to see more and the cross the
light Pros
I'm going to add the CSS file in the
description box this main area.js file
CSS file in the description box you can
check it out and also you can add the
folder and just improvise this project
coming back to our code
processors and then the
uh angle down
and the color will be below let's have
blue now
okay
font size
to him
him
and this is looks fine
see
yep
in your head let's work on the main part
after the students I'm gonna create
another Dev
last name
near area
and this div let's add
a story by first take this story but we
are going to add these Wheels part which
shows you I am going to cover it in my
next videos
till now I'm going to cover these
shots or status
let's move on this
again inside this main area
okay
yeah
let's continue
again I'm going to create one the
classroom
that's right
story
yeah
nice
create another first stories button so
let's set up this part here
story
yeah
yeah like this so I am going to add one
image here
to Source the image would be
fake
and the folder images
G
my friend
three four
six four
Dot
let's try this part here little
how it would be
excellence
which would be 50
brackets
then the water radius
he would be fine
okay
let's close this
and after that
what we will do is Select break
let's add the
by six
yeah
and after that I'll read
above
let's save it first
let me declare or let's say do it in
here
it will save our time also
so what we are going to do is we are
going to copy this
part
from here
let's copy this and let's write
paste it one two three four
minutes
yes so let's
change the name of these
link
because Flash
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so we're going to write all of them in
one go
okay
so after these let's change the name of
these images
okay
see the names okay
yeah
seven
equal six
eight five five
nine two six seven
two six seven
left left is three to seven
three two seven eight is not General
it's nine two seven one two
project g p and g
let's try to simulate but let's try it
free energy
foreign
[Music]
this is your screen
let's create another day of class
name text
after this training lists of class
opposed
so disposed I'm going to write
the med source
then Breaking Inside the images folder
and ID
3464.wg
foreign
let's move forward
let me just copy and paste that
but here so you I'll explain you after
that
now I have added all the code which was
left here
as you can see
after this image I am taken one input
text
in this info it was a type of mind and
the placeholder which will come inside
that was what's on your mind
and like this we have closed this line
again we are calling some icons for that
these icons are like this
like the second the second and the
second
after that I have declared that in that
I have to check the names of that part
like as you can see here
okay then
this is one image content
that I have
shown
I have declared one image or simply
learned inside that simple level
is the image link after that it's
uploaded and his cover image things that
are written on Facebook when you appear
to upload a picture or something after
that there is this div class of caption
inside that please comment like share
and things which comes into captioning
people write things like that and after
that it's the comment like shared in
that things button okay and after that
we'll come to the left side of this
speech here I have written contact in
all of the icons that magnify glass icon
that we see on Facebook page that we can
see here in the Facebook page you will
see that the contacts this room option
search and this name data online or
these are all your friends so I have to
tell you some of my engineers and inside
that I have declare these things after
that it's completed and then we have
exported the file in the first case only
so now
we'll save this file and already I have
added all the CSS file
all the CSS is done here
you'll have the folder Link in the
description box you can just copy all
the things and enjoy
it's now add the
port
let's try it
just
f a angle you'll find these
well you'll find everything like very
easily
Facebook image I'm not done so let's if
it's not faced down then it will just be
like a light color then you can just see
it's wrong okay
angle down is done
throw some flag
on your friends
search
and from that you move your head
commence
that so it wasn't thumbs up
[Music]
that was she is here
yeah
everything is imported now
from
react
icons
slash everything
okay now we have already
taken some from MD and AI so again I'm
going to write import
it's not fetching okay
so we can see the issue here no problem
MD
and there was another name
from
okay icons
yes
it's not coming where
spelling is true
everything is fine now
it's just uh this morning
image from
here
react
icons
yeah
let's save it
and see for any issues
the station coming
the fake credit is not defined okay
maybe I have to clear one
okay
it was declared but you've got automatic
okay it was
spirit
that's compiling successfully now let's
see the output are you ready
so this is our page
isn't it looking amazing
right
these are the story by its name in the
and this is the picture that I have
uploaded you can like comment and share
it
you can write anything if you are
feeling anything like video These are
the small things that I have shared with
you you can anytime improvise this
project
okay
now
let's close this coming back to our code
let's open the Chrome
and I'm going to write Instagram
and this is how at the end of this
tutorial you will see your Instagram
clone okay
so
let's jump to the coding part open your
Visual Studio code
now let's create a react project
for that open your terminal
new terminal
you can also open your terminal by just
pressing Ctrl plus back time okay
here I am going to write a command to
create react project is
npx
create
react app
now the folder name I'm going to create
as insta
Instagram clone
okay
it'll take a couple of minutes to
install all the files in libraries
so let's wait a minute
as you can see it's installing react
react Dom and react Scripts
so let's create a couple of minutes more
I'm sure at the end of this tutorial you
will love the output as you are going to
create a straight simple and fascinating
Instagram clue
okay let's wait a minute more
okay
now
okay it's taking a minute more it's fine
we'll wait a minute more for this
after that
I'm going to open half folder here
I'm going to create a react project
like in this Instagram clone I am also
going to create the login page inside
the login page I am also going to create
the sign in page when the user enters
their view ID and password
they will be redirected to the home page
now
let's see our application is looking
first we are going to go inside the
folder that we have created so I'm going
to write
Instagram
clone
now we are inside the Instagram clone
let's open our folder
where all the files are
so inside the C
users SLP
here is my folder let's open it
and see
now we'll open the terminal by just
clicking on control back tag
here I'm going to write
npm start to see whether our project is
working fine or not
so
let's wait and see the magic of react
react is a beautiful library of
JavaScript okay you'll love the output
in the end I'm sure
let's see
so here it is the beautiful logo of
react
now coming back to visual studio code
let's install the material UI component
of react for that I am going to write a
command
let me just search here
icon we need core
powder
open this npm
you want to open this one
but let's copy this command from here
it's copied coming back to a code let's
paste it and enter
let's move to install all the files
okay fine it's saying
the other root folder
okay let's just see in this Json file
comes I'll be installed or not
okay
so there are so many packages here the
react is all dependencies react even to
your Dom your script
and
this score is not installed let me just
again
find them okay
let's write npm
install
just a minute
yeah right
4.11.2 okay
so it will install automatically
here I'm going to open this app.js file
and as you can see this let's run this
file now and VM start
let's say it's working fine or not
okay it's working completely fine
now coming back to our code
let's delete this logo we don't need
that
and let's delete this header
here we'll write H1
inside this H1 I'm going to write hello
from Simply learn
let's save it let's see what's the
output
isn't it looking cool
at the end you will see in complete
full-fledged Instagram clone it'll be
awesome let's see Instagram
okay fine
let's delete this one we need
to move forward
and
delete this one
because we don't need it
also I'm going to delete this file also
let's delete this image
okay
here
now I'm going to create component as
react is a component based Library here
I'm going to create different components
for this project
let's create a folder called compo
Nance
inside this components folder I'm going
to create a folder called
login
page
inside this login page I'm going to
create two files as login
Dot login page dot Js
and
inside this login page only
let's create another file called login
page.css
now
instead let's just save it for now
okay open your login page to us CSS not
TS
port
react
or we can also write
import react
comma
here I am going to write
component
yeah
from react yes
I'm going to create a class of login
page
inside this login with extends I'm going
to use drops in state in this
component
let's create a Constructor
inside this let's write a prop
this let's try the keyword super
props
after this let's
this dot state
get the state inside this okay
now render
this function
to return
div
hello
world
let's save it
okay we need to export
export
to export each file you need to write
export
default
and then the file name
like login page let's close this one
let's save it
everything's look fine
now coming back to app.js
here I'm going to write
login
login
page
and as you can see
it automatically
imported the
login page from components login
okay
let's just save this one and see the
output
so
it's working fine
come back to our code
let's
this part
okay it's fine
let's import react
after this
I'm going to
we're also going to use the grid system
here okay
code
okay let's
let's add a grid here so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to make the screen
into three parts like three
to the left side three to the right side
and six to the middle
okay as you all know
so the screen is of 12
so I am going to use this 12 okay
let's
open our login page
in
pieces
and let's create a div now I'm going to
show you how to create the
internet screen
firstly I am going to take one div
inside this div I'm going to write
create
container
inside this grid container
to add one grid
item
of exercise
3.
okay
should not come under this it's
okay fine
yeah
and I'm going to write some demo data
hello
to just let you know how the grid system
works
now
to create one another let's
swim
proper
hello
here I'm going to write from
here I'm going to write
simply learn
let's save it's showing an error
okay
let's find out the theater
everything is looking fine to me
let's see what's the issue here
okay the grid is not defined okay it's
fine fine
got to add the grid
okay I have added one command for the
grid yarn add material UI code as this
was not working
so I'm again going to add the material
UI
so let's see that what we find now or
not
wait a couple of minutes to see
if it work that will be great
so let's just see the Instagram
login page for now let's just log out
from here
okay
let's just open this
Instagram yeah
this is how
I'm going to create the login page
so I have these pictures this one this
one and this one
so inside this
sign up page I'm also going to
create this signup page and this login
page okay
so it'll be very great if you'll
understand the process
the react is a very beautiful language I
love react
so if you love react
do subscribe to our Channel
post
amazing videos on a daily basis
so this is almost done
now I'm going to start this project
will not work within previous let's
let's this
let's see is it working or not
okay fine it's working
so as you can see it's saying okay let
me just delete this part
index.css let's delete this save it
coming back to our beach
let's just save it
now
as you can see this is taking what this
piece which is
from here to here
okay
and this from is taking
space from here to here this Big Grid
and this simple learn is taking this
much space only three
so we have distributed this 363 inside
this 6 we are going to work
so coming back to the code
now we are going to create the login
page
so let's
hear
and said login P dot GSS
JS let's add here yeah
inside this let's cut it and let's
create a Dev class
okay
inside this let's create another div
with this div I'm going to add one image
let's write the source of a DOT image
it's
insta
website against image
okay this is not necessary
okay that's why it's not fetching we
have to import the image in the top
so let's write import
instead
just remember whatever you are getting
inside this
we have read it here also so
this is inside the source
inside
the
folder dot okay
first it is inside the Instagram clone
then Source then inside that images
now inside that
I have added one image folder here I
have added some images they'll be
important and useful in this tutorial
okay
I'll give the link in the description
box for this project you can just get it
from there okay you'll get all the code
don't worry just see how everything
works okay
so here I'm going to write the code of
that image it was 9 3
6 4 6
okay it was seven five f
B two six
a sweet G
now let's save it and see the output
okay
it's saying we are packed compile with
one warning it's nothing image element
must have an old okay it's fine we can
do it in the CSS part
oh and boom you can see the output here
isn't it amazing we can just adjust
everything don't worry about that
but it's working
let's
you can add here like alter this image
hide width we can give
okay
now let's move forward
and add the width
let's give it width as
okay we can give the width as
and pixels let's write okay
450 would be fine
yeah let's
please here
okay yeah
it's completely working fine I wouldn't
give the padding and all
for now
it's looking beautiful yeah
let's open that page where that
yeah it's already down let's again login
we'll face this login page okay yeah
it's up so let's make it
up only okay
yeah it's looking very beautiful
coming back to the code
after this let's create another div
let's inside this let's read
okay we have to make the Box
so let's
okay let's you can also add the image
here
yeah
now we need what let me just see once
okay we need one container inside the
window we need that image
of Instagram okay fine it's easy
no big issues
okay
let's
right here again this
copy okay it's copy
and now let's paste it
so the name
so the name of this is not insta image
it's in
install logo
so what we are giving not right now
let's not go it's fine if we can
okay we have to include this
inside here
okay
let's
copy this import
paste it here
and install logo
from images
75b206a
yeah it's fine
let's add the name
insta
logo
dot PNG let's save it coming back to the
code it's showing error can't resolve it
okay
let's Okay okay fine
I understood
so
it's not it's done it's insta
let's save it
now is it the same issue
it's the same issue
let's search for each time with DOT PNG
okay fine
now coming back to a code
we'll see
install logo dot PNG
okay fine everything
it's local and star
in just a minute
it's not this one
it's the
okay let me just find
lower things as here
let me just
there
okay
let's write here
save it
yeah
it is working but the image quality is
very bad
moving ahead let's find the another logo
is there any low Bond size here
we can use this logo insta
let's try this one logo insta here
but
let's save it
let's see is it yeah this is also
working fine
okay
go with this one only
hmm
to the code
okay this one is fine we don't need this
word
this one
now let's give this first as a class
so if the CSS properties
okay
so for that I am going to give it a name
as login page
and Main
let's just save it
and inside this okay let's just delete
this one
no no
to write
login
page
in
go inside this
I'm going to write display
then it should be
Flex
save it
coming back to the code let's see
okay it's fine
now again I'm going to write login
in
we need for log only
so that's coming
the next line let's give it the width
I've already given it over it so we'll
cut it from there
let's
write CSS in different pages
let's not mix it here
okay
let's see
coming good bye
unfitted I guess
but no issues we're gonna make it work
yeah
login page
go with the Cs is not working okay
I forgot to add the CSS in this login
we also have to
add this CSS so I'm going to import
Dot
login
page Dot
CSS let's save it now and see the magic
of CSS with
react
okay
different things it looks good
okay
back to the code
it's looking very slow
choose evaluate a couple of seconds
because
working
little kids
let's move forward
we can add new features inside this
so
we're going to add this logo head
what is coming
here
you want this that
set this so let's
login
page
right
permanent
say this
is going to write
okay everything is good
good height we're going to get right
let's give it a height of 380 as
it is as Instagram login page
[Music]
then
the border of that box which is one
pixel
solid
[Music]
let's give the exact color that
Instagram have
okay let's just save it now
see everything is attached
okay
let's just see
the Instagram one is looking very big
here
let's reduce the size
155
let's see the warnings here
it's still compiling okay let's kill
this terminal
delete this one
inside this creating new terminal
let's try it and start and see whether
it is working
Define or not
let's just delete this
okay
it's coming inside that the only
let's see whether it is fetching the
login page
login page mean as correct
you have to add the
files here to fetch it okay
let's just copy this one
add it inside here
first let's read
right component
here
list
class name as login
beat
let's give thanks devil
login
right
let's just save it
here here also
for this image let's give it the class
name
login
beat
logo
save it now and see whether it is
working fine
okay let's hope it's working fine yeah
we have created one box and this is what
our Instagram logo
pop it up
let's open our
terminal
so
that's
right
it's fine
we don't need this one
one for the main
or one for the script container to the
speed container
I'm going to add one
once
two
we have created one div here
yeah it's fine
now it's looking
up
like here earlier it was looking down
now let's remove this
till now I'm sure you have
gotten the idea
for why we have taken this
okay let's make it
thematic
yeah let's save it
now
as you can see
in our app
and in Instagram
there is this one
margin on the top
so let's open our CSS
where I'm going to write margin
25 pixels let's save it
yeah
our app is also looking like the
Instagram login page
right
and then it started looking cool
right okay
let's make it as here as it is showing
inside there
yeah you have to give betting to this
Instagram
like
you have to create this also
let's
give it some space here
let's
let's give it margin top to everything
so it should align C
uh inside the main also
I'm going to give margin
55 pixels okay
now in this rate
I'm going to give it a border which is
fine margin is fine
margin is what fruit top we need so
let's save it
this Dexter Lane is
Center so our Instagram will
be inside this container which is Center
isn't it looking very similar to The
Original Part
now let's move forward
with the next step inside this container
I am going to create
these phone number and all okay
let's work on this container open your
login.jss
yes file
after this
let's create
a Dev
inside this let's create another div
so
yeah
there are two divs
there's some space in between these and
this
so it's fine
I'm going
to
open this
let's read
class of login
page
i g i n
just written the wrong spelling
now let's write input text
inside the you have to use the play cell
you have to use that placeholder
like you also have to write these things
now
okay
let's write
similar input for password also
input type okay
or text
type which is
I am asking
let's type
and the type of this is password
let's
forward
see
yeah
for username password we can just make
it
looks similar to the original one
with the help of
what CSS right
let's create a button
let's write sine
okay
let's just save it
you'll see one sign button yeah like
this
coming back to the code
let's write
let's
okay here we are
let's make it with CSS you have to get
class name
last name we are going to give
let's name it simple only login page
next
type of this let's copy it from here
and let's paste it here
for button I'm going to add another
class
as login
button
let's just save it and see the magic
it's not showing let's see what's the
issue warming
okay
I did the CSS and why we are expecting
so many other things okay
first we are going to add the
for login text
and I'm going to write these three
page width
let's write 258
which is the exact same
height
which is 36 pixel same again
I've inspected these things so I'm
pretty sure of that
login
button
inside this let's give it a width
of
70 only
because the button should be
small
now let's see
yeah
okay we need to do some
changes here also we will it's coming
outside of this container let's see
is we have added here inside the
container
okay
okay here I have done few changes in the
dev
now
as you can see
it's coming inside the container now
we are gonna give some space so for that
let's give them some margin within your
piece dot CSS
and here
I'm going to give it a margin
of 5 pixels
okay
also I'm going to give it a border
because color is very dark there
I'm gonna change that
solid
and
DB
yeah
and this is looking good
and we have to create one more
which is
login
page
sign in
yeah
inside this let's give it a margin from
Top as
25 pixels let's save it
and see the changes yeah
so
now the color of this is looking exactly
like the
this one now coming back to the button
part
let's just
add the
bit
will be creative field it here
oh
as you can see here
it's not coming inside this because we
have
open this one in the
let's close this
let's first add the placeholder or let's
work on the button bar okay let's
just add the placeholder which is phone
number user anymore
email
so inside this text now
we have to add this
placeholder
after this I am going to add one
placeholder
it is going to tell us what's
comes inside this
number email
or
usually
okay
and inside here let's create another
placeholder
select this let's write password
let's save it okay it's called
the email is coming
username
or
save it yeah
just looking amazing
right
now coming back to the CSS file
let's give it a background
yeah
after the Border we are going to give it
a background color which is a little mix
of white
so I'm gonna write hash
f a f a f a let's save it
now it's a little bit
dark white okay
same as
this original one
yeah
moving forward
let's now
coming back to the code
let's
cut this one
let's write this
okay
uh we're going to give
padding left too
10 pixel
yeah this is coming fine
let's just
add one more which is
border radius here
5 pixel is fine yeah
no
okay let's give
the spot in some height
after the height you're going to give it
border radius for 5 pixels
after that font weight
let's give the font rate bold
and then we will order for this
which is 1 pixels solid
and the color would be
okay let's see the color here
in the original one sky blue okay
bye
the sky blue color is zero three nine
five F six let's just save it
okay
it's coming great
but let's just
sir
because we need background color of this
as blue so
3956 yeah it's a little dark
okay
and the color of the button should be
White
so
you can just
let's see yeah it's coming beautifully
right
whenever we hide the ID password Here
yeah
okay
forward
let's
work on
gifts
to minimize this
let's
add here 40
we need to
we need to add the DOT
background
color
and the background color of this would
be
a little
you just see the original one
okay it's
it's fine
okay
it's right only so we'll write FFA
yeah this one is great
okay
coming back to the right one
the center we're going to give it
back around
color which is white save it
now let's give this button a margin
margin
from Top
because we need to add some space here
so we are going to give with the margin
of 5 pixels yeah this is the line now
now
let's see whether it is looking fine or
not
so
it's looking completely fine
so now we're going to split the screen
as power and all
so coming back to app.js
now we'll work on this part
this or
log in with Facebook in this everything
coming back to code
here
I'm going to create one Dev
let's minimize this we can see the
output
okay
let's create one div
inside this div I'm going to create one
div
modif
and inside here we're going to write r
okay
looking cool I guess
save it okay with all is coming but we
need to add some CSS here
so we can just
make some space here so let's
write this class name as
login
space
divider
let's save it
okay
let's give this one also class name
as login
or
here also we need to get some
class name as
login
divider
okay
now
you should also get this one last name
because
we need to I did this also in the CSS
I'm going to give it as
if
let's save it yeah
let's open our CSS file
let me just add the CSS here now
here I have added some CSS properties
you can see it
okay
so let's just save it and see
this is the r
now
let's work on this one
though
login with Facebook forget password okay
let's move
okay
so I have added one class of log in
Facebook here I am adding the image
where this is the keyword FP which is
can fetch in the import
login with Facebook and then another div
of class name login forget
password
and
here
I think this FB
from the image folder let's just save it
and see
this is how it is looking we need to
shrink the size of this image
let's see the original one first okay
it's coming very small but in our case
it's coming very big so what we can do
is
you can go to our CSS file and reduce
the size of this
login Facebook
so I have added here
margin top is let's add 10.
and see the changes
nothing is here
so let's wait
okay let's not
ice the
here we can also
add the margin
right
so why can't we give the width here
it's right width
15 pixels
and let's see
yeah it's coming beautifully
right
now
coming to this password
you can make this as a hyperlink also
okay
but let's just give some styling to this
look and feel let's
a little less
okay let's just do it now
so
let's give it margin right
let's save it
for the image got lost
okay we just have to give
exactly
number which is
5 pixel now
what it is saying it's saying this okay
okay
this can't be fixed from here
and it's again
okay we have given
now it will be fine
yeah
yes it's looking good
now
we'll work on this
sign in and sign up button
let's just
go to our
project
here we are going to add
because we need to come out of that main
container
okay
so here I'm going to create one another
container
let's give it a class name of
login
page
okay
sign
up
options
okay
inside this let's create another div
class name
login
page
sign in
let's close this now here we are going
to write
don't have any account sign up
copied
and here we're going to paste that
right
now
we are going to create another Dev
let's
let's give it a class name as
login
page
sign up
it is
let's write
down
sign
foreign let's just save this one and see
our page
yeah it's coming
up
what we can do is
let's see what's the mistake here
it's coming inside the container but
it's not fetching inside this
okay
this one is fine
get the sign up button sign in this
thing
this one is looking good
let's add it here yeah
now it's working fine
yeah
now what we can do is
you have to give this a little bedding
so it comes under this
so come back to
line up
the top base
you don't have an account sign up
you don't have any account sign up
and then oh we need to add
get app
let's first form this now
get the app
let's minimize this this one also
refresh and it's coming perfectly fine
as I'm not going to add these data we
can do that
but I'm not going to do that
so
let's add some images like this one
here
for that
let's write here
oh clone get the app after that
I'm going to
create one another div
at this I'm going to add these images
okay
images source
store
close this one
to that again
image
source
Play Store
let's save it
okay
we have to
add the images imported
just a second
yeah
let's import this app store and Play
Store images
copy this one
called B
paste
that I'm going to write
App Store
and here I'm going to write Play Store
and the image name is
app
and this one is play
let's just save it
and see
okay it's coming very big we need to
give it the width also
let's
code
everyone here we are going to give it
some width
let's give this one
136
pixels
yeah and let's copy this
that's
yeah let's paste it and
yeah you can see the output
we have to make some padding and all
okay let's coming back to our code
let's give this one
sign up page or let's
let's give it another
okay
let's let this one only
let's fix this
let's give this images
class name
as login page
one
options
yeah
now let's copy this
and
to this image
I'm going to paste this one
let's rename this option as
and here also
you are going to let's save it and see
it's there's changes
get them
it's coming really
get the app yes
do this only so let's do something for
that
let's add here as
load
position
okay
let's
this one inside this div
is this one
let's see it's still in the background
okay
let's just do one thing here
now it's looking fine yeah
so we need to give some padding here
let's give it some padding
Here Also let's just copy this property
only
paste it
save
now it's coming beautifully
yeah
there is some Gap here so let's
add this
watching motion
okay
edit this t w i n g but
okay this is the mistake
I thought it's not fetching the right
margin
it's not fetching the right margin
let's just
from the CSS
there right
top save it
margin is fine
okay we need to give some margin in
between the
container and get the app okay
so let's just see
in download section
say the download section we need to give
maximum petting
from here we have given some padding
buds
and things were fine so let's right here
40
the login page option is also 40.
but it's not getting the space I want
so let's open this one again
it's a login option
and log into it
with this one
Martin
top
fetching this one
okay it's fine it's not that big deal
so
login pages
done
so this is our login page
and this one
is Instagram login page
so
whose login page is looking more
beautiful guys
I understand
so let's move on to the home page
code
here inside this Source component
I'm going to create one folder
insert this component folder
folder
iMat
of home
page
inside this homepage component I am
going to create two files
let's name each of them as
on dot Js
and the other one is
Dot
CSS
yeah
save it
just
let things look fine now let's open
let's delete
this also
you have fetched the login bet yeah
everything looks good
let's create
hello
Port reaction
yeah but I am importing component
[ __ ]
okay
let's import the CSS file of this
hold
home dot CSS
okay
let's create a class of home
now we'll see whether it is working or
Not by giving it a dummy text
okay
let's maybe use our props again
super keyword
fetch props
and this date will show us the
date of the program okay
[Music]
trend of
whenever you are calling the you need to
declare the render function
so
let's give it
hello
from Simply
let's close this
again
need to export
all
file name
let's save it and let's import it this
page
inside the app.js
now
as you can see we have already imported
login page
now I'm going to import
home page
now
or home from
components
each
okay
let's save it
let's see is this in the browser
showing some errors
it can't be it cannot it's the
location
it's inside let's see the structure of
this
okay let's go this
is
the source
it's component
red
of this folder is created let's
cut this one
paste it here
okay let's cut it now
now it should be working fine
let's cut these files
now it will be fine
what is showing
hello from simple learn right
coming back to our code
to Instagram page
so this is how the Instagram page is
looking
what I'm going to do is I
create one nav bar in the top
s navbar component which will include
these icons so we'll get plenty of space
to add the
uh stories in the vector and this box
here is
an end of
pi
then we'll follow the same let's
code
inside this component folder
another folder
does
now in this I'm going to create
JS and
the
cssful
yeah
I'll never
dot Js
2
CSS okay
now coming back to
let's do this
coming back to
with
copy this
this
and paste it inside number.js
edit the
like nav bar
or GSS component
render
here
port
okay
nav bar
let's save it error let's see what's it
is
what should
okay everything
to invite just
okay
it's right here as
member
so we can just
get what it is showing little
page take this
delete the whole thing we don't need
this
inside this I am going to declare the
net bar
we faced in the single page
okay
let's make inside the step
okay let's
let's start now
let's
save it now
things
or get swing let's save it
let's create one more
it's components only
main component
blow it back
thank you
inside this main content will create
again two files
10th
Js
and mean content dot CSS yes
okay
now
again we'll go to home copy this text
going back to main content
let's delete this right
Main
content
let's delete this also from here
in 10th
also this
yes
let's okay
here
we go create everything fine
let's save it now
it's done
let's see
let's go to home it
here call
this mean content
let's save it and in app.js
let's comment it down for a while
which
find
here
okay
okay
now.js in my body
page
oh
Lord
save it now let's see the
key
pepper
and mean content okay
so
as you can see
that's these files okay
let's develop easily
component like a button mean component
now
inside this nav power.ts
let's
let's bar
create one there
is
r
okay let's
close it
now here
I'm going to use
grid
from Material UI
okay let's save it
okay
as you can see
a one component has been created
let's create now
create hit this
let's give it a name
great
container
inside this container I'm going to call
for
victim one is access
let's do
let's just copy this from here
well let's just save it
okay
let's
okay
let's see
good see
there is this issue that was coming
so I checked and the grid was not
properly installed in our system now I
have a game called what this command npm
install
slash four
this F is denoted as forcefully
and again it is installing material UI
core
it will take a couple of minutes install
all the properties upgrade
it's sweet
let's
analyze them
this will be your soul while
so we have to import the sales number
also
and these icons we can get it from the
material UI
icon and one company for the
pictures
and one component for this
go back to our code
it's still installing
shoes
let's just add some text
so you
get
now
and that is never only
let's import
logo
that we needed
logo
as you can see
you can see it is installed all the
packages
installed in the system
we are installing that
go
for that
let's add here
inside the images folder there's a
picture called logo
and stop
and G
okay it's fine let's
go
this part
yeah it's
cut this okay
let's first just you know whether it is
working or not
let's pull this one
see you
in the editor
let's find out
so we have
finally compiled this program
successfully main problem was that
I was declaring it
should not come under
module so we have to import it like this
so
output of this program is like this
this is the component which is
the main goal okay the things which will
come under this as Story part
profile back upload that part and here
is sedation part
the neighbor
declare the Instagram logo
okay inside this
let's add it here
let's go here and the image we have
already imported the
image on the top
let's write
install logo
with this one
save it
showing a big Instagram logo we don't
need that we can
change it in The Styling bar
happen
let's
give it a worth
let's write
pixels
save it
okay
foreign
of let's just delete this part
space
yeah
this little spoon
right
back to this
let's
all right
input
text
Ure
please Google
placeholder is what you know guys
let me
it
is complete that box you
will implement ing this search box yes
yes okay
let's create
here
come
inside
three three six seven eight
minutes
let's go and train you know
Style
set this I'm going to add
display
which should be
Flex
okay
it's this
and let her import some
image
everyone fine
by the ways
let's give it away for 25 pixels
save it
copy this one
fine
yeah let's
go back
so when it's on one is
Siege
other one was
that drawing button
now
as you can see
it comes the grid of the screen is 12.
so we have used 11. now I am going to
create
here
let's give it size of
one
and that would be empty
okay
now let's import the images on the top
again
that
is
name of that is
okay let's paste it
oops
much
yeah
let's write it between
what's the name of the images
react
here
save it
on which this reactivity
let's see
let's see
now let's check
okay
it's coming beautifully
so
actually
yeah
you have to get strong icons we can also
write these names but I'll take much
space so
as you have noticed there is one
file portion also
which is round and inside that
there is a picture
so what we can do this
let's go to a code
see
okay
here
let's give
class name
bar
search bar
yeah
save it
it's
everything which looks fine to me
let's create this
I mean
no
this is the time we can
add the
logo the
Beats
each this one
back to the code
what we can do is we can import
Avatar
UI core check this this
which is this one
head
yeah
no
could declare this inside this
so what we can do is
star source of the image
DB
what this image
the
let's first
image
Style
okay
and inside the style I'm going to give
it
Max height
Max height
let's try it
sign us
25 pixels
then
where did
let's give it as
now it's looking good
excited again
five pixels
just close this one
as it is showing letters because we have
been imported the
image
so let's write DP for
let's write the name of the image
and to
save this one
still showing two errors let's
them
Parts Azure inside this network.js
what's together
up let's just click to one more terminal
and let's call this one
okay
set the network only I installed
but let's just run this one
right
so what we can do is
I'm actually locate this
this we can remove now only
with the prominent problem
let's see
can do
or not found
very images
images
what
support okay
bottom
let's save this
so whenever we find any error just copy
that and paste that inside the
Chrome
and stack of flow you'll find plenty of
answers of that
so our main issue is with the avatar
maybe it's installed or what
add this
okay
it's read some documentary there
okay
let's find out
again it's the same issue
save it and see
whether
it's working fine
yeah it's just coming a little
in that properties
shows that
let's give
a little more size to it
and let's see now
Beyond this one is looking
fine
okay
yeah
coming back to the code
this
no
let's style them properly
okay
back here
to this image I'm going to give it the
class name
because
limit
what we will need
like this
image
okay
yeah
let's just copy this
and paste it here
here
and here let's save it now and see the
module
yeah it's coming beautifully now right
everything is aligned and you can see
the nav bar very beautifully aligned
now
this is not looking very good this main
content let's remove that first
okay
yeah
let's remove this one let's
see now you see this is how the nav bar
is looking
isn't it beautiful
forward
coming back to visual studio code
everything is fine I have added the CSS
properties you
will
upload all the code in the description
box you can just copy that from here
okay
let's
move ahead
now let's close this
here says
the main content we will work on
yeah
fine first thing first what we are going
to do is
I'm going to import grid here
here so uh
let's remove this
and let's
add the proper location of the
tree let's
yeah
grid
container
inside the script container
I'm going to add two grids
is
size them as
to
six first
okay let's
let's right here
great
item
six
main thing what we're going to do is
inside this
Okay so let's
make
space
let's create here
okay
on
put it here also let's complete the
structure okay
now
where we can just
add the size here
okay
is fine everything is look good now
and start working on this
so let's
let's
add
let's first here you can
yeah
in the components part
let's create two folders or components
see this
state is by
okay
and then status bar again we are going
to
create
to files Js
CS
status bar
CSS yeah
right now
we are going to create one another
component
which is main page
in in this main page folder
it's not folder
install it as
okay okay fine yeah
okay let's create
in page
and select this main page let's
go again
base dot Js
I mean
we dot CSS okay
that's the mean
page
and the status page it will come up
because data should come
okay
let's just
capitalize this
okay let's save it yeah
everything's look fine now
let's import these files inside this
first we'll import the
status bar
um
status bar
did this one yeah
again we are going to import this
page
from
you can
yeah let's save it
now
as you can see here
just got it because you haven't declared
anything inside this
status
here
now let's just
last part
with a class name
as me
and
container
in this saver
back to status
I'm going to import
okay let me discard this part
copy it from
the place
cut this one
if
it's going to repeat this
okay we just have to import the
Act
component
from
you react
yeah
let's just save it import
file
which is important this is a status bar
so it is bar dot CSS
seven
eight
Take This Bar
in the function
say also
default
if the status version
let's just
we don't need this
status bar
okay
let's just copy it from here and set
this
let's paste it
store some modifications here
mean page
okay
let's save it
here also
and page
and
when it comes to exporting the file
set the tab
yeah
now I will see the output
so
this is our nav bar this is the status
bar this is the space that we are giving
to this
status bar and this is the space which
is the mean page which
yeah coming back to the code
I'm going to create
class name
status
status bar
integral
where all the stories will come okay
right
so let's create another div
status
okay let's close this
here
yeah
after that it could change it
let's save it
on top
ICS
beat this
but
status
source
status image will again
please
status
r
still yep yeah
okay yeah
let's just copy this YouTuber
it's just
do it
let's add the images now let's
both
status image
from
methods
while food
save it
okay it was
see
yeah
isn't it looking amazing yeah we have to
align it but
you can see the status bar let's add
more
status let's let's copy this
and that two three more here
yes save it now let's see
yeah
this is looking really very good okay
you have to align it into the center
okay
yeah
let's
come back to the code
let's see
now what you have to do is you have to
make this container that status part
into the center of this mean page
you can do it right
okay fine I'm going to add the status or
the pictures here you have to add the
container into the center on your own if
you need any help you can just comment
it down I'll help you out okay but now
you have to do some things
so that you can learn about this
technology mode
now we'll work on this main page
okay
now
let's create a folder here in the
components as post where we'll add the
pictures inside this again I am going to
create two files
JS and the CSS for The Styling yeah
post.css okay fine
now what we'll do is
let's copy this
and paste it inside this yeah
and
from here
we are going to give the right path
post
let's get the class leave post and then
we are exporting here is post yeah
save it
now
let's encode this into the main page
okay
it's showing an adder let's see
what's the
in there
okay
we put we will imported it
the reason it's showing this this error
post from
post
and then post
let's save it now
let's say this
okay this is file
maybe let's cut it from here yeah
paste it here now save it let's save
this also
everything looks fine now yeah
now
how we can check this is working or not
is
you have to add here
hello
save it
this would be fine yeah it's working
fine
now we can add the pictures here
okay
let's remove this instrument yeah
let's start working on this component
let's read this hello
inside this first div let's create a
class here
and let's see matters
most
until
yeah
now
let's leave it as
the
you have to remove it after that but
let's just now
the better Clarity of this program
to
read this okay
again I'm creating another div
in
like this you have green right
okay
let's
do it
yeah
okay
let's delete this
next thing
let's create a tree like this
yeah
okay
yes it's fine
one component we have to create there
okay fine
inside this first header
what I'm going to do is
let's see the Instagram component
okay
so there is one image
and the username okay
on
let's
okay
inside this tab let's create a class
post
retailer
okay
after that
inside the another container
let's right here of thought because we
need to add the
logo
okay so let's give it a class name
of host
images
free
and let's write the source which is
the
that I will
send
okay
yeah
now one thing more we have to add is
that you have to add the username as we
discussed
you have to add the username so I'm
gonna write post
username
and then inside this
okay it's not necessary but let's write
the username
okay
in this component
I'm going to write the
image okay
show the reference like this
names and all okay fine let's move
forward
imported
let's save it
we use it okay we can just
change it after a while it's not an
issue
now
let's move to the image component let's
inside this div I'm going to create the
image
source of the image B
post image
let's add the width here
with this
let's write 600
six
pixels
let's just save it
you have to add the English for now but
it's fine
okay
now let's emit the
import the image
Dot
post
image
from
images
photos I'm using this picture so many
times
okay
let's save it now it should be
completely fine
yeah
so with this
we have created
are simple
for beginners
Instagram clone
so with this we have reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
it
let me just show you in the last how the
login page was looking
okay let's just
show this
save it
you will find the code in the
description box don't worry if you have
any questions you can just ping me down
and I will also add this part in the
code
in those sections part
so with this we have reached to the end
of this video I'm sure you enjoyed
watching this video do like share and
comment thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign